I only venture at this moment
re-establishing control over this
continent and every person on it my
allies are gone I'm losing you can count
on the iron back as soon as the gold
arrived
enough with the clever plan
hey guys Pete here it's going to be my
Game of Thrones season 7 episode 4
trailer breakdown you just saw the
trailer and looks pretty awesome
has to say I felt a little more invested
in episode 3 even though I liked the
first two I thought this one was the
best so far but I'll talk about that in
my recap and review which will come out
after this so we start off and we see
psycho no stars from the iron bank of
Braavos we see that he's there to talk
with Cersei and she looks pretty smug
because she knows that she's going to be
able to make good or at least you think
she's going to be able to make good on
their debt to the bank she tells them
that her only venture at the moment is
to take control of this continent and
every person on it which is pretty
ominous I would say but from her
perspective at this point things are
definitely going her direction after
Tyco and Cersei we cut to the beach
where we see that the king in the north
and Daenerys the clean are meeting with
their closest Council it's not exactly
clear why they're on the beach here this
could be before they enter into that
cavern that we've seen for the
dragonglass but you know there's no boat
nearby so it's not like Jon's leaving at
this moment or anything we see fian land
here later but he's not in attendance so
we'll just have to figure that part out
we see that the very confident queen
that john met when he first came into
the throne room is now in a different
position
she says all my allies are gone I'm
losing now the unfortunate reality here
is is that there's not much John would
really be able to do to help her and as
I said in my video about their meeting
he really has no motivation to do that
he knows the threats coming from the
north and that it doesn't matter who's
going to be sitting on the throne if
everyone's dead
so her fortunes have turned pretty
quickly after landing in Westeros
after that we get a couple more
Lannister sequences we see bran for the
first time he's with Jaime they're
overseeing the transport of their spoils
from Highgarden we see Cersei talking to
Tyco again and he gives her conditional
support and that condition is on this
large cache of gold that we see in the
very next scene
arriving to King's Landing where he'll
get paid so that's a bit ominous I would
say but let's move on and we'll talk
about it after from there we see the
cat's paw blade which has been the stuff
of a lot of speculation we see this is
and it looks like it is Littlefinger for
sure he unsheathed to the blade and
that's confirmation that he still has it
what he's doing with it here is not a
hundred percent sure but I have a
feeling that now that he knows brand has
arrived which he wouldn't have been
expecting really he's not as safe as he
once was if he really understands the
nature of Brandon what he can do which I
imagine he at least has heard stories of
Bloodraven and whatnot he knows that his
lives won't really protect him because
bran is a little bit more powerful than
what would be good for his healthier so
yeah let's move on but so we see another
shot of Daenerys then and now she's
going on offense I don't know what a
better way to describe it would be she
says quite simply enough with the clever
plans which means she's ready to bring
fire and blood and my interpretation of
that statement you guys can let me know
what you think but then we get a few
more sequences of different images we
see that again we see the convoy
traveling with Jaime watching over it we
see Jon Snow lighting a torch
underground we see pod hit the ground
probably still sparring with Brienne
like we've seen before we see fian has
made it back to Dragonstone he's landed
on the shore get another shot of Jon and
De Niro
and I guess this does this scene does
tied together why they were on the beach
could be before this or could be after
this but yeah he's got Daenerys and the
sign the following him and they're going
in to look at the dragon glass see
literal finger was a uncharacteristic
nervous kind of look on his face he's
definitely deep in thought they're a
sequence of Brienne looking tough she's
bringing her sword down I've seen some
people say that this might be a
beheading but it doesn't have that look
at all to me I mean it looks like she's
in the you know the practice yard
I feel like there'd be a ceremonial kind
of setup
if it was her chopping off somebody's
head then we see Arya looking at
Winterfell so she is coming back I guess
we'll see her there in her arrival next
episode get a quick shot of Sansa she's
got some parchment in front of her and
we don't know who she's talking to here
and guess and then we see the closing
shot of the dragon swooping down concede
Daenerys on dragons back there and we
could see that she's putting into motion
her idea about letting go of those plans
and bringing down some fire we got a
guess that this is going to be related
to that convoy that we saw right I mean
we've seen that that battle goes down in
the trailer so yeah that's coming up
she's going to attack so yeah I was it
was a good episode episode 3 it was a
good trailer here to get the hype going
I think it is safe to say that
everybody's position sort of switched
around and I assume that they're going
to continue to do that throughout this
part of the season I don't think
anybody's ever really going to win so we
see that Daenerys tried it the way that
her advisors told her to Cersei
basically outclassed Tyrion Cersei and
Jaime I should say Jaime is in charge of
the army after all she's taken some
major blows probably regretting the fact
that she didn't just walk in and take
King's Landing as yara said at this
point but that's it you know there's
there's not much anything happen about
that so now we're going to see her do it
the Targaryen way in the Dothraki way so
that's going to be for some pretty good
action I think it does appear that
John's going to get his dragonglass
it does appear that the bank is not
going to be pleased if that gold doesn't
make it back to King's Landing
now if Jaime is smart he'll figure out a
way to get that gold back no matter what
everything else can kind of go to the
wayside but he's going to be in a battle
I mean we've seen in the trailers he's
basically fighting for his life so I
don't think there's a good chance that
that's going to make it back
Littlefinger pulling out the cat's paw
is definitely some serious foreshadowing
about his situation in his look I mean
he could try to kill brand that might be
what's going on here but we also know
that arya has arrived or she is arriving
so we don't know what the sequence of
things are but there's going to be three
Starks in Winterfell
that's all good news Littlefinger is at
a very weak position may be the weakest
position he's been in brianne's there to
protect Sansa we've seen that I guess
that's what that's for there right and I
have to say in the last episode I was it
really I like the new songs that
everybody always loves to hate Santa but
I like the way she was handling
Littlefinger and I think that she has
advanced and then another thing to get
hyped about here beyond Daenerys taking
things into the Dragons hands or
whatever you want to say beyond arriving
at Dragonstone while Jon is there I mean
we all assume that that's what's going
on should make for a very interesting
encounter all right so that's about it
I'll leave it there I'm going to get on
to my recap and review I'm going to
re-watch again and get ready to do that
so please like this video if you liked
it and subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already that hit the little
notifications thing after subscribe so
you'll know when my new videos come out
I'm doing a full schedule I have been so
check my videos from last week and check
out my
and review when that comes out follow me
on Twitter and my other social media
accounts and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon